first let's thank cena for stepping up
in heroic fashion to uh
speak for us thank you
um
cena's uh
[Applause]
seen as uh
i guess my first and only postdoc so far
uh together with david day i guess maybe
it was officially david's but you know i
felt like we're you know cool parents
and uh now a professor at northeastern
has a joint appointment in philosophy
and computer science so he's another
weirdo of the right of the right kind
and cena has uh
you know
um
a really special ability i think to just
kind of
casually uh trespass across disciplinary
boundaries um
and in a way that you know maybe um
isn't all that concerned with even where
they are and so it was really i've
learned a lot from working with cena and
cena's work has i guess prior to
philosophy was working and also
cognitive science
um did a phd in philosophy and then came
over sort of
got interested in things going on around
the
moral and political questions people are
asking and around fairness and machine
learning
um tom spent a couple years with us at
cmu um
he's collaborated uh you know worked
with folks in philosophy department
worked with folks some of my students
from machine learning from natural
language processing
um
in a way that you know is i think really
inspiring so um
really glad to have him with us and uh
to see his talk so thanks enough for
stepping up for us
thanks zach uh
and thanks everyone uh so given zach's
introduction i should say in advance i
apologize for
uh the last minute talk so zach said
that i work on uh
that have been working on
interpretability a little bit i should
say that it's been
quite tangential most of my focus has
been on
issues of fairness and diversity in
machine learning systems
and diversity more generally and i think
but some of these themes will come true
through the talk and i should say that
many of the things and teams that i will
be talking about i will be drawing on
some of
the previous discussions and joints uh
work that i've had with my
great collaborator maria di ortega who's
at ut austin
so kind of the basic motivation
for
what i want to talk about today is that
obviously with the use of machine
learning systems in all of these
sensitive domains like people have
started taking it seriously to evaluate
their impact evaluate their properties
and maybe intervene in the way that
their design so so as they kind of align
them with our social designer with what
we care about right
but uh in many of these cases uh
i think it's fair to say that the focus
of this evaluation and intervention
practices
has been on
uh
the predictive model
itself
there's one part of the pipeline
and in some previous work i've
criticized that and i know many people
that are in this room have criticized
this type of narrow focus on the
predictive model
uh
for instance because we are just
focusing on the model in a static
setting we might lose some dynamic
aspects of the impacts of the model and
so
what we think is the right intervention
at the model level in a static sense
might result in long-term impacts that
actually decouple from our intended aims
but what i wanted to talk about today is
just this other basic things that in
many social applications i think
uh that
typically motivate papers uh typically
make the news these models are actually
not decision makers right they're used
in decision support capacity that is
they're used to provide predictive
recommendations to some human user or a
team of users that can then use these
recommendations to make decisions or
maybe actually ignore this decision
but
they
act in that kind of decision support
functionality
and the basic question for me is that
when we actually take this
functionality of decision support
seriously
how should that change the way that we
think about evaluating and designing the
systems
and given our focus on interpretability
how should that change in particular
some of the ways that uh kind of maybe
typical discourse especially among
i would say
maybe some the technical literature but
also in policy and ethical analysis
about the relation between
interpretability and accuracy and
particularly the supposed trade-off
between the two
and uh to put my claim uh there i come
as i said from a background of thinking
about multi-agent systems and complex
systems so obviously
i'm going to say that the norms that we
have for thinking about individual level
performance and what might be the proper
performance and what might be faulty
performance are quite different
from what we will have at the group
level and sometimes at the individual in
the group level we really want something
that at the individual level might not
look that good
so that should change the way that we
design these systems and should change
the way that we evaluate them but
this is typically unfortunately uh
not taken into account and then we can
think about why so
uh let me start by saying
what i mean by the standard view that i
said like typically ignores these things
by standard i don't need i don't mean
anything bad by it it's just like the
typical way that things are done
sometimes it's good sometimes might not
be good
i think it's fair to say that in many
cases when we are designing this model
the models are
kind of chosen on the basis of which
model fits a particular objective better
which model minimizes a particular loss
function right which might also kind of
maximize accuracy according to some
particular measure
but uh
the way that the headlines will put it
on the way that the many research papers
put it even in cases where the model is
supposed to be serving or assisting
human decision makers this is done in a
way that
has this narrative of competition that
is the model is outperforming the user
in this predictive task and the common
assumption is that when we choose a
model in this way the model that
minimizes some loss function for
instance that's also the model that is
going to be best from a decision support
perspective
and the challenge here is to make sure
that this human decision maker
actually is going to add here with this
decision so that their behavior is not
kind of
uh
does not exhibit algorithmic aversion
for instance right so we don't have this
good model there and the expert is
ignoring it
now of course there might be other
things that we care about other than
accuracy right there might be models
that are very accurate but either humans
don't use them as i mentioned or
patients might not trust them
there might be a list of other things
that we might care about anything from
kind of improving responsibility and
safety of decisions to
enhancing trust both by the user
decision maker or
society or decision subject
fostering autonomy again by the user and
by uh
the decision subject enabling recourse
for decision subjects so that they can
come and question the decisions so that
they can have
ability for let's say informed
uh self-advocacy and so on and so forth
and in many of these cases
it is thought that something like
interpretability explainability
maybe in some different sense is going
to serve those purposes
now there's lots of questions about how
the same thing
could serve all of these things whether
there are different things that serve
all of these things
i will put all of these aside and kind
of proceed with this nice formulation of
uh
the cost of imposing interpretability in
some sense that in this paper that shai
has with some colleagues
uh that's okay we have these other
things one typical way of thinking about
them is that we can turn all of them
into some type of bias or restriction on
the way that we learn particular model
so this is i think
quite a standard in many ways that
people think about fairness they think
about fairness as some type of
constraint on our learning so instead of
just learning as such we learn or
minimize loss subject to some type of
fairness constraint again
i'm not a fan of that but
i think this is typical
and we can think about interpretability
in the same type of say so restrict our
attention to a subset of potential
models that we could learn
now
how do we decide what that subset is
let's leave it to a side according to
some let's say complexity or something
else
but
the worry then of course is that when we
do this this might have a cost because
obviously instead of searching for the
best models in the overall hypothesis
space like this said we are just
focusing our attention on a particular
subset that and there might not be any
overlap between them or in the best case
scenario the predictive accuracy of them
might be similar to each other
i think importantly this type of view
about the relationship between these the
two desirata accuracy and
interpretability is
quite widespread in uh ethical and
policy engagement uh
with this domain so when people are
trying to decide what type of models we
should use in particular domains like
medicine
i think many cases people take this at
face value they think that it actually
these two things correspond to some type
of value trade-off
so for instance they say oh in some
cases when we are deciding how to
allocate some limited medical resource
we care about fairness and
interpretability
right or wrong
it's taken to promote fairness and there
it's okay to sacrifice accuracy but in
certain other cases when we care about
diagnosis maybe we just care about
accuracy and then we don't need to use
an interpretable mod
this is
some of the way that people
make proposals about what type of model
we should use in a particular domain
but the common assumption obviously here
is that model level properties are going
to map onto some type of system level
property that is
if i say that i want a model because
it's uh because i care about the
accuracy or quality of decisions
i should choose a model that has is the
most predictively accurate i should not
sacrifice for the sake of
interpretability
so this is like what i mean by the kind
of is a standard lens where
the narrative is kind of the competition
choosing the best model according to
some measure but that best model will be
the best model also for decision support
and that the
properties of that model if things don't
go wrong like for instance if the humans
don't exhibit certain types of
uh
algorithmic version build maf onto the
properties of the system in the best
case scenario ideally
but obviously when we look at things
from not the pr from the perspective of
the properties of the model but from the
perspective of the properties of the
team that we actually care about
then things might be quite different
because at the group level sometimes we
have to actually make sacrifices for the
properties of a parts of a system
brother system in order to make advances
for the same property at the level of
the system
so
let's just see like
the way that
this is typically talked about in the
literature on group decision making
uh
so
when we look at the group decision
making there are different types of
mechanisms that are involved the shape
the quality of decisions of the group
on the one hand we care about
the cognitive repertoire of cognitive
attributes that individuals in the team
are bringing to a common task and on the
other hand we care about the processes
by which we actually
elicit and
integrate these distributed information
across the groups
and in each of these two processes two
components of group decision making
there are different types of things that
could go wrong right
in terms of cognitive mechanisms if
everybody in the group thinks in the
same they have the same type of
limitations uses the same types of
knowledge that is if you have
cognitive homogeneity and informational
homogeneity
then
we are not going to be in a very good
situation in terms of uh dividing labor
in complex tasks if i get stuck
somewhere my teammates will also get
stuck there if my information is
corrupted with noise or has some type of
error it is very likely that also my
teammate has the same type of
information that is has those
problematic things on the other hand if
you have diversity a cognitive
informational diversity
if i get stuck somewhere a teammate
might actually be able to do something
that i can't do and so as a team we do
better
if i need confirmation and it comes from
a teammate who actually looks at the
situation very differently their
confirmation might actually mean more
which is like a typical day of
when we discuss a methodological
triangulation
and similarly with the way that we
uh integrate the information but uh i
will just focus on this
idea of cognitive diversity the way that
in teams what we typically want is to
have
diversity of
cognitive attributes among team members
and i think that
uh maybe like a toy example can really
show the value of this type of cognitive
diversity by in the way that they enable
complementarity and performance uh in
the human ai team
so assume that we have a loss function
that uh measures the predictive
performance of different individuals so
given this loss function we look at it
and the lower obviously it is the better
so we see that the predictive model a1
is the best on this predictive task and
assume that all of the individuals are
doing the same task which is not
necessarily true sometimes humans are
doing different things
so
we can ask is the model with the
kind of lowest loss the best decision
support model and the answer is
obviously it depends we might need to
know more about
the way that the strength and weaknesses
of these models and
their users is distributed across
different cases
so suppose instead of just knowing the
average loss function we also know the
loss function across different regions
of feature space
and suppose that they're kind of all
equi equally probable
when we look at this type of different
regions then we can actually see how the
strength and weaknesses of each of these
members
might complement one another so
this model is very good here
but this human is very good here
and when we look at this variability
within and
between agents in performance
then we can actually put things together
in a way that forms better teams teams
that are better than any single
individual
so this is for instance if i knew all
those loss functions and for each region
i just decided to go with the prediction
of the individual that is best at that
region
in that case this team
even though it does not include the best
individual performer is going to be the
best team
right
so
from a systems level perspective the
most accurate predictive model is not
necessarily going to be the part of the
best team and
same type of thing of course you know
there's a smaller uh setup or subset of
literature that does try to incorporate
this into machine learning design right
so sometimes you can do this by
uh changing your objective to make sure
that the model
if it's making mistake the mistakes are
in places where humans are good
in other cases you might decide to defer
on cases where the model
does not have enough confidence
you might defer to experts again
complementarity might arise if experts
are actually good in those cases
otherwise not
so the broader point
and there are many different instances
of this there are dynamic instances of
this when we update the model and the
performance of the overall team might
change but the broader point really is
that
when we are thinking about the
functionality of models in this other
capacity as opposed to autonomous
decision makers thinking about them as
decision support systems
then we have to consider
norms at the right level otherwise we
are kind of committing a categorical
mistake we have to uh consider the norms
at the system level
both modes at the system levels and the
potential tradeoffs such as diversity
stability at the system level
and it's been important because the
model level properties do not
necessarily map onto those system level
things and i i should also note that
uh same type of situation i think also
arrives for issues of fairness so i've
been talking about interpretability but
the same type of thing you can mention
it in terms of
discussions of fairness under
composition but sometimes
different parts of a bigger system it
might be many different algorithms that
are all doing a particular task like
misinformation detection have a property
that you like from a furnace perspective
but the overall
pipeline might not have it
and i think this will also have
implications for that case
and i think it's also important from the
perspective of not just what
interpretability is which i will get to
in a bit but uh
the aims of interpretability so so many
times we say that they care about
autonomy of users or
the decision makers that use this system
i think uh
thinking about this from this system
level perspective
is a kind of a meaningful way of
promoting that autonomy or promoting
that trust
i think
when we consider situation from this way
through this lens of system level lens
then
policy proposals that
suggest uh simply that in certain cases
where we care about accuracy we should
ignore interpretability
if we just take it at face value that's
going to be mistaken at the very least
we should know that this interpretable
model cannot give us something else and
not provide us with a way to make the
human decision makers better or very to
make the group better than any of the
individuals
i think this can also result in kind of
this type of uh off the shelf uh
justifications that are based on
category mistakes so i like uh
my uh predictions to be accurate and
therefore
are my decisions to be accurate and
therefore i should go with the most
predictive model and you might lose all
these other possibilities
okay so
i said the
in that case that interpretability
might
even if at the level of the model might
be detrimental to the performance or
might be seen as detrimental to accuracy
at the system level it might provide
a better predictive performance but
one could
wonder
whether interpretability itself is
useful or required in this sense or
something else can
that is very only means to achieving
those or whether there are other means
and if it is a means
interpretability in what sense can we
make it more specific and for what type
of task
and i think literature here is a little
bit uh
i i wouldn't say divided so
maybe maybe divided and mixed uh so
there are literature that shows that
interpretability can benefit the
performance of the
uh human ai decision making teams but
they typically focus on cases where that
interpretability is just help the
decision maker overcome algorithmic
aversion so it doesn't actually discuss
complementarity
the works that focus on complementarity
i think
they suggest that
more or less that explanations actually
undermine our aims of complementarity so
remember that
when we care about complementary
performance we really want each team
member to actually
kind of uh
assume responsibility for the part of
the task that they're good at
and
delegate responsibility otherwise
but in many cases it seems like
explanations actually make the users too
comfortable so they rely on the id
predictions too much such that when
their expertise is needed they don't
actually contribute
and in some suggestions some other cases
the suggestion is that if it simply will
provide confidence of the model
that might
give us better reason now some of you
might think that okay that's
transparency or interpretability enough
for me providing these confidences for
and some other people might think that
well
that's not really interpretation or
explanation
but i think we can uh kind of go
beyond this by thinking a little bit
more about some of the prerequisites of
complementarity so
i this was the case of complementarity
that i had this is the
uh
the performance uh
distributed performance of the human and
this is the model so notice that here i
am assuming from the perspective of
someone who is integrating this system
or choosing a particular model
that i know what this regimentation of
space is so suppose that i don't know it
and i have different types of uh
averaging it so
in this case i have this coarser grain
regimentation of the space
where i am looking at the average of
this and average of this and same for
this
when i look at things from that way
actually there is no complementarity i
look at these things okay yeah adding
uh this model or adding this human
together we cannot have any
complementarity here because the model
is better than the human in both regions
now if i
average things in the other way
suddenly i can see potential for
complementarity right
so
maybe this and this is kind of similar
getting similar to the some of the
things that david was discussing is in
terms of the interpretability of the
not representation but the regions where
uh somebody might be good so maybe some
clustering methods but maybe some
aspects of the interpretable machine
learning and
explaining with the explainable ai
approaches can help us in figuring this
out
but this is still based on kind of i
think observed performance and observed
error in particular cases maybe we can
go more fundamentally by thinking about
kind of what actually at the deeper
level different individuals might bring
to a task
and
in some of the cases based on just image
classification it seems that
humans and machines make very different
types of mistakes on different tasks
so
obviously i think you can
guess which row is the road that is
difficult for humans and vitro is the
road that is difficult for machines
uh
because i think this row b is the road
that is difficult for machines and row a
is difficult for humans but very easy
for machines
so
i think
one possibility here is and that this
is particularly i think suitable for
cases when we are thinking about medical
diagnosis
uh to
maybe even go further and think about
what type of perspective or kind of
representation of a particular problem
do individuals bring
right so if they're latching on
different latching onto different
patterns
in the
let's say image or in the particular
task then
that might give us some reason to form
teams in that way
and maybe we can even
combine it with these discussions of
russian onset that i know that many of
you have worked on it that have been
discussed in relation to uh fairness and
interpretability but not i don't i don't
think that much with in relation to
complementarity
basically thinking about from the set of
models that have exhibit similar type of
performance which one of them actually
exhibits complementarity in terms of
representation at a deeper level with a
human decision maker
so is interpretability required or
useful i think we need to be kind of
clear about overarching aim and the user
so
do we want better performance than the
status code than the human decision
maker or do we want actual complementary
complementary performance if you want
complementary performance then we can
think about different prerequisites for
complementarity
and we should also think about
even with that focus useful for whom
that is with respect to what aim
we wanted for a system designer that is
choosing which model to use to a human
being to the human decision ex human
expert human decision maker even if they
don't want to kind of say anything more
about the model to the decision maker or
do we want to
uh
the interpretable in the sense of uh for
the information integrator which might
be the human user itself and in each of
these cases we have different measures
of success we might have a model that
overcomes a human's uh
algorithmic aversion and so it's
successful in the case of
improving performance compared to a
status quo but it's
seen as a failure in terms of
complementarity
when we specify that maybe you can have
a better sense of interpretability but
um
yeah so the overall point i think which
is pretty obvious is that uh
what we want from the system level might
be different from what we want from the
individual level it's easy at the
individual level to focus on the
properties of the model
but if you really want the
the use of these systems to make our
institution as good as possible then uh
you need to consider those rather
system level norms and
this is another paper we don't really
discuss this here but the this is
another case where we try to go and
consider
to consider uh
how
identity and demographic diversity can
be beneficial throughout the pipeline
and that's the thing but this is again
like the same type of experience of like
what would happen if
at each point we go beyond one label to
consider
a diversity of labelers and so on
but yeah
anyways
as i said you probably noticed the last
minute part of this but
thank you for your attention
[Applause]
um
so um i think this is an implication of
your view but i just want to make sure
i'm understanding it correctly which is
if i care about accuracy
it's entirely possible that actually i
should ha deliberately have a model that
is not interpretable
so interpretability is is just a means
to whatever the system level
characteristics are that i would want
because you know if the user the human
decision maker is somebody might game
the system i might want to deliberately
obscure why i made the decision why the
algorithm yields the decision it does or
the recommendation it does
so that the human can't game the system
is that
do you endorse that implication
that sometimes actually i should design
my algorithm to mislead trick obscure
things from the human
decision maker
uh so the the shoot part is obviously
the heavy ethical part that uh to the
mislead but but if we yeah
yeah i i think that that's a that's a
fair implication that if we care about
the system level performance
sometimes uh
it might be the case that the model that
is not interpretable serves some of the
aims that we want so if the model that
is interpretable again in some sense i
don't know what sense
if it uh
creates over reliance
then perhaps i don't want it actually
perhaps i want another model that
uh
increases vigilance i know so yeah but
from that perspective
these two things can come apart
now follow that
i think that creates difficulties right
because who decides i can have 10
different
incomprehensible algorithms
and then you you may have to choose
which one are you going to wrote it out
to see what happens
but then can have a lot of
possible dangers that you don't know
right so the idea is that
uh that makes the kind of design task a
lot more
difficult and fragile you know instead
of just like we choose going with the
model that
uh
we think fit certain types of properties
we have to consider all the types of
perturbations that might come from
particular types of users what they take
to be incomprehensible but they take not
to be
kind of incomprehensible
and i think
so
i'm not suggesting that we should go
with particular types of users but i i
think that there is the particular type
of explanations that
uh or explain explanation related
behavior that humans exhibit that they
kind of
uh defer to certain types of explanation
even if the explanation is irrelevant
and
i definitely get it that humans have our
biases and very strongly the question is
how do we prove or show or have
agreement that the machines will not
create even more biases
without understanding
what what the machine does so i maybe we
should continue at the panel yeah yeah
right now
thanks ben thanks xena okay so
uh we can reconfigure for the panel
which i think just means putting some
i promised everyone a
bathroom break
so if anyone would like to go to the
bathroom
now's your chance